REMARKABLY WE HAVE DISCOVERED IT
IS STILL GOING ON.
YOU NEED TO KNOW ABOUT THIS.
WE HAVE NO EXCLUSIVE INFORMATION
FOR YOU IN JUST A MINUTE.
AT FIRST, A REMARKABLE INTERVIEW
WITH FORMER
PRESIDENT BILL CLINTON.
FOR DECADES AS HE WATCHED BOTH
CLINTON'S HAD LICENSE TO DO
ESSENTIALLY WHATEVER THEY WANTED
TO DO AND THEY DID.
FELLOW DEMOCRATS WOULDN'T
CRITICIZE THEM AND NEITHER WITH
THEIR OBEDIENT TOADIES IN THE
MEDIA.
THE CLINTONS RAN THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY, SO THEY WERE TOO
IMPORTANT TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
THAT HAS CHANGED.
BILL CLINTON IS NOT POLITICALLY
IRRELEVANT SO THERE IS NO LONGER
ANY REASON TO PROTECT HIM.
THE MEDIA SMELL BLOOD.
HERE FOR EXAMPLE IS WHAT
HAPPENED WHEN BILL CLINTON
VISITED THE TODAY SHOW THIS
MORNING TO SELL A NEW BOOK.
THE CONVERSATION WENT DIRECTLY
TO MONICA LEWINSKY.
WATCH.
>> BUT YOU DIDN'T APOLOGIZE TO
HER.
>> I HAVE NOT TALKED TO HER.
I HAVE NEVER TALKED TO HER, BUT
I DID SAY PUBLICLY ON MORE THAN
ONE OCCASION THAT I WAS SORRY.
>> Tucker: OUCH.
HE ALMOST LOST IT AND THEN SORT
OF RECOVERED AND THEN HE WENT ON
TO EXPLAIN THAT EVEN THOUGH
MONICA LEWINSKY'S LIFE WAS
COMPLETELY DESTROYED BY THAT
EXPERIENCE WHILE HE HIMSELF WENT
ON TO BECOME THE SINGLE RICHEST
FORMER PRESIDENT IN HISTORY, HE
SOMEHOW IS THE REAL VICTIM HERE.
WATCH THIS.
>> DO YOU THINK DIFFERENTLY OR
FEEL MORE RESPONSIBILITY?
>> NO, I FELT TERRIBLE THEN.
NOBODY BELIEVES THAT I GOT OUT
OF THAT FOR FREE.
I LEFT THE WHITE HOUSE
$50 MILLION IN DEBT.
YOU ARE GIVING ONE SIDE.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, I'M NOT --
>> DO YOU THINK
PRESIDENT KENNEDY SHOULD RESIGN?
DO BELIEVE PRESIDENT JOHNSON
SHOULD HAVE RESIGNED?
>> SOMEONE SHOULD ASK THESE
QUESTIONS TO YOU BECAUSE OF THE
WAY YOU FORMULATE THESE
QUESTIONS.
>> Tucker: IT WENT ON LIKE
THAT, IT'S PATHETIC.
THAT'S PRETTY MUCH IT FOR BILL
CLINTON'S LIFE AS A PUBLIC
FIGURE.
IT IS OVER, BUT WHAT DO THE REST
OF US LEARNED FROM WATCHING ALL
OF THIS?
IF YOU ARE A PROGRESSIVE LEADER
THE LESSON PROBABLY IS DON'T
ABUSE WOMEN ORDER TREAT PEOPLE
AROUND HER LIKE YOU WOULD LIKE
TO BE TREATED, RELATIVELY FEW
ELECTED DEMOCRATS COULD LIVE UP
TO THOSE STANDARDS.
THE QUESTION IS THIS, DON'T LOSE
POWER.
AS LONG AS YOU ARE USEFUL TO THE
LEFT, NOTHING YOU DO WILL BE
HELD AGAINST YOU.
YOU COULD LITERALLY, I DON'T
KNOW, DRIVE OFF A BRIDGE AND
KILL A WOMAN IN A DRUNK DRIVING
ACCIDENT AND STILL REMAIN THE
MOST ADMIRED DEMOCRATIC